欢迎收看最佛心幽默的财经节目
理财达人秀
我是李兆华
今天是8月的最后一个交易日
整个8月我们涨了3008点
而外资也在8月是大幅的买超
不过今天最后一个交易日
外资是转为卖超
其中有一个原因是上个礼拜五
华许说话了
其实听起来跟之前的讲话没有太大的不同
但是现在9月联准会升息一码的几率
飙高到了50几%
这让美股的科技股又产生了压力
那它会不会影响到接下来9月的行情呢
以今天台股的收盘来说
我们还是世界强哦
盘中又跌到800多点
但尾盘MFCI的季度换股
把它给拉上来
中场只小跌了202点
而今天大家最关心的新兴电子
上个礼拜五有跟大家聊
也许开盘得先走一趟
但是走不掉啊
成交量好小
但盘后筹码
投信不但没有大卖
还反手买
这代表什么意义呢
今天要好好来跟大家做解读咯
来欢迎今天的三位来宾
第一位是股市施工永年老师
好 永年老师
之前就提醒我们这一波台股会反攻
但是滑雪的一席化
让现在九月升息的几率往上跑
往上跑美元可能会转强
外资可能会落跑
我们要不要担心呢
现在施工说
首月线就不要太担心
而今天盘面上可以看到
所谓的会不会有新兴电的转单股
有一些PCB是很红的
这一些其实涨的不只是转单
等一下施工会告诉您
更重要的是
手上有新兴电的人
本来早上觉得我卖不掉好痛苦
但盘后一看
投信在买
那明天我该怎么做
等一下施工也有独家的看法
第二位是题材恋人
汉伟哥
汉伟哥也要讲
今天MSI拉尾盘
里面有一个成分股很重要
叫做记忆体
我们有全世界最强的南亚科
今天创下收盘高
那其他的记忆体
到底能不能跟上来
卡在什么样的条件
等一下汉伟哥跟您说分明
因为业绩真的叫做超级好
另外现在苹果光打得亮晶晶的
除了光学股之外
散热板材也有受惠的
尤其是多題材更不怕等一下來教你選喔好 第三位是我們的冠軍操盤手雲翔哥雲翔哥今天有大獨家他又參加了比賽淨收益目前達到1億元
到底排名到底幾
今天會告訴大家他的策略
另外看高做低
後來教您其實SpaceX相關的喔
現在美股的評價是提升的
台場供應鏈那麼低
有沒有便宜或可以減
還有就是半導體展
帶您去看裡面的特化股
已經有人先領頭搖表態
一樣看高做低
還有哪一些潛力股呢
好 首先有請施工 永年老師
好 沒有想到
華許在講的時候其實我有聽
但是是不是因為
外國人比較聽得懂英文
就看到美股撲通跳水
想說怎麼了
好 但是台股今天其實還好
尾盤還拉起來
那再來的話很多人都想問
有欣欣怎麼辦
網傳了很多
PCB有很多的社會股
可是最奇妙的是
今天投信没有大看星星
本来明天想要排队去卖的人
要不要先等一下
是 好 来我们先看一下
这个滑雪他到底讲了什么
让美国股市大跌
其实他只有讲的
真正重要的是一点
这个美国通膨还是高于2%
我们的目标就是要把
就是你看他还有工作要做
就是要把这个通膨率压到2%
大家一听那就完蛋了嘛
对不对
所以本来的这个预估
它們對這個9月要升息的機率
結果一下子就跳到將近60%了
可是今天來講
你不要說我們台灣的股市
是開機走高
就是留了很長的下影線
你看韓國股市也是開機走高
日本股市也是一樣
開機走高
所以看起來這個事情
大家也已經有點麻痹了
有點習慣
就生拔讓它生這樣
對
那就不理它了
好 那麼我們看一下月線
月線這個月的月線
剛好收了一個大力光
就是3008
3008是大力光的代號
對 就是大力光
那麼其實這個月能夠收3008點
真的已經很厲害了
為什麼
因為7月份的時候一跌
大家就已經嚇得要死了
會不會反彈一下
然後9月份
現在大家最擔心的9月份
會不會跌得比7月份還慘
我們如果說從這個K線來看的話
那麼我這樣子講好了
這個9月份的它的日均量
要達到1.15兆如果能夠達到1.15兆的話它收紅的機會會比较大如果没有的话还是什么八九千亿的话那可能这个要拉回来整理一下
这一点可能要注意一下
那另外我们从日线图看的话
今天留下了
我记得是600多点的下影线
非常长的一个下影线
而且它守住了所有的移动均线
连这个五日线都守住了
表示怎么样
这盘还是非常的强势
那明天非常的重要
为什么明天呢
理论上来讲明天收个红
应该要收个红
可是万一呢
它明天是收黑
而且把今天下影线吃掉一半
所以简单的讲
它只要它的明天的跌点
超过350点的话
其实对于多头就比较不利了
因为今天放亮嘛
今天有亮
然后呢又留很长下影线
对不对
表示呢有洗盘成功
可是明天如果再收黑的话
就表示今天是拉高在出货
尾盘拉高在出货
那这样子反而不好
所以要特别的注意
那月线跟季线是多头
一定要守的地方
那如果守不住的话
那技术面就可能有转弱的机会了
所以稍微的要小心一些
好 再过来我们看台积电
台积电我们上个礼拜就讲了
它在那边做个收链三角形
我们看一下日线
早盘开低
然后一度打得很低
把这个月线 季线全部跌破
然后你注意看
它这所有的短中期的移动线
全部都纠结在一起了
全部纠结在一起有什么好处呢
它是极端好或极端坏
为什么
因为它今天还不错
是今天除了五日线之外
它其他的线都守住了
它其实收在最高
而且它只小跌0.62%而已
没有错
所以表现其实不错
它明天如果能够再带量
再拉出一根长虹的话
那么它所有的移动均线
就有机会一起向上翻扬
那你知道所有的移动均线
都一起向上翻扬的时候
那个力量是很集中的
它就可以把这个股价推升上去了
那过去的三个礼拜
外资其实在默默的买超了1.5万张
买到不多
可是融资余额也减少了2027张
这一点很重要
因為台積電一直是
我們散戶的心頭好
大家都很喜歡它
所以零股什麼用融資買
都買了一堆最近這三個禮拜融資餘額反而減少盤久了就有没耐性的人可能不想要融资买它了没有错就减少了
所以它的筹码面来讲的话
反而对多头是比较有利的
那我们就等它的一根长红出来
因为它一表态
这个指数就不太一样了
另外就上礼拜五
我们就提到星星
那在过这个周末的时候
其实案情就有比较明确的进展
原因出来了西产地
而且重点在可能不是载版
是所谓一般的PCB产品
然后又大概15个人被抓去调查
所以到底这个事情严重性到哪里
欣欣也出来讲
就是它是PCB产品
那我们相信它是PCB产品
那PCB的产品对它的业务
到底有多大的影响呢
我们可以看一下
传统PCB呢
它只占它的总业务的
大概9%到11%而已
其实这占比并不是很高
那我们现在就要等消息出来
它到底是是不是
究竟是不是只有传统的BCP
有受到影响
如果是这样的话
那其实真的没有很严重
以业绩来说没有很严重
对 没有很严重
所以你看外资还来送暖
外资不怕我维持买进
那美银不怕
我的目标价还是1400
那瑞银也是一样
我不怕买入的平等
OK 好
那统一投顾的说法呢
它是这样子
是 为什么用统一投顾
因为婉婷在这儿
是 没错
所以听听看女王怎么说
对 没错
那它疑似PBC产地
那它这个跟这个产品
跟ABF载版无关
所以影响是可控的
还有呢
这个比较重要
美国客户不会更换
ABF载版的供应商货
调整订单比例
为什么
因为现在每一家的ABF的
这个载版的那个订单
都满到一个爆出来了
对不对
谁有办法去接这个多出来的单子
都没有办法
所以都没有任何厂有能力接转单
所以应该有限
应该有限
可是如果是PCB的话
我这样子讲
或许会有一些集单
短期的集单
它非要出货不可
现在又不能出了
所以它只好去找别人做集单
可是以长期来讲的话
我也觉得影响不会太大
好 所以同意同步的看法是说
它對於股價影響應該小於20%
所以
因為他有提到說
之前有美超維拉群聯
它是財報的問題
那個可能事情更加嚴重
那個很嚴重
對 而這件事情的話
與它的財務
看来没有那么大
所以他是用这样子
不过股价要怎么样走
不是说这样讲就OK啦
对 没错
那我们可以看一下
以欣欣来讲的话
那么我们这样子讲
OK 他今天一个跌停板
对不对
那么理论上来讲
不会超过三支跌停
不会吗
紧绷 最多最多
因为就像我们刚刚讲了
因为它并不是什么
这个很严重的违法
做假账
或者是這個出B貨
AE訂單出到B貨去
那麼不是那麼嚴重的事情
所以我覺得
應該不會超過三支停板
那可是到底會怎麼樣
因為還要看到時候
它的高層程訊跟內控的危機
還有就是基金還有ETF
會不會抽資金
這個外資晉級它其實是買超的
它成本它是比較高
也許會在低檔自救加碼
這一點大家可以注意
其实今天外资跟投信
就已经有进场去买了
好 今天很有趣的筹码
就是外资投信是小幅买超
对 小幅买超
那我们散户要等什么
等底部出非常大的成交量
比如说
对 比如说8万到10万张的时候
然后它的跌停板
都按照10万张
跌停板一定会打开了
那么到时候呢
它只跌出大量只跌的时候
我们投资朋友在看
它反弹起来的力道强不强
如果反映起來力道很強的話
那可以考慮這個持股續爆
就是你原來手上有的股票
繼續暴漲
好 但是我想頭兒朋友在意的
應該是明天如果再吃一根停板的話
我能夠沉得住氣嗎
還是該怎麼處理
我覺得就像我剛剛講的
不會超過三支停板
明天就已經第二支了
對不對
應該說第二點五支停板
所以我覺得
應該可以沉得住氣一下
好 沉得住氣
當然這邊的話底部放量
在考虑进场
因为有人想抄底
是 对 没有错
再来考虑一下
那现在呢
大家最担心的是
这些ETF会不会卖掉
因为真的
持股比例非常高
对 持股比例非常高
7% 6%的
那所以呢
大家会担心
可是呢 我这样子讲了
他们会不会担心
我觉得他们不太会担心
对不对 为什么呢
因为呢
我不卖
大概就没有什么人卖了
那也要这些人讲好
好不好 要這些人講一般的操盤手他不會那麼在這個節股點上卖不到卖也卖不了多少对 所以何必呢何必自相残杀好 那我们今天看了
因为理论上来讲的话
大家本来是想说
如果是ABF宅板的话
那么这个南电跟景硕
应该会占到便宜
对不对
结果今天景硕
他盘中反而打到跌停板
他有他自己的问题
对 那其实呢
他的问题就是说
大股那种申报转让
大家一想
我们在这么高的高档的时候
申报转向是不是有问题
大家会害怕
那事实上应该不是
就是创历史新高了
我卖一点股票
有什么不对吗
当然何硕
他有蛮多的转投资
是可以做十分的
然后再来说
他今天是新兴最好的朋友
最后他也跌停板
但理由显然是不太一样的
没有错
那我们再来看南电
南电就不太一样了
南电因为你可以看
它基本面是没有问题的
然后它今天也是一样
早盘的时候冲上去
然后又打下来
结果看得很可怕
你知道吗
结果它最后收了一个十字线
而且它是守住了所有的移动均线
所以理论来讲它是非常强势的
虽然它股价是收黑的
可是它是收个小红十字线
而且它的量能是增加的
所以其实我们要把它当作多头来看
就是当作空头来看
那重点就在说明天呢
它如果能够再继续收一根红的话
尤其收根比较长的长红的话
那这档股票呢
应该还有更高点可以值得期待
因为呢其实你可以看
上档呢其实并没有什么大量掏扰压力
那手上想要继续投资
载版的朋友需要把星星换成南电吗
现在换大概也来不及了
为什么呢
就像我们刚刚讲的
因为你明天如果这个星星再跌停的话
它要不然就出很大的量
要不然出很大量
那出很大量拉起来的话
你也不用卖了嘛
是不是
那如果没有打开的话
你也卖不掉
所以呢
这个议题不存在
好
那么我们在之前
有跟大家介绍的
好 七月底的时候
讲到创意
创率是新高
金居大反弹
对
那后续要不要继续操作呢
OK
金居我认为说
应该还有一些空间
像他今天呢
成交量很大
结果他收个小红十字线
所以這個其實對多頭是比較有利的
是有利的嗎
對對對
那如果創意的話我是比較認為說稍微先看一下為什麼因為最近很多股票都是创了新高以后就快大幅度的拉回那所以呢可能创新高的股票可能要稍微的这个谨慎一些
好
那我们再来看呢
PCB呢
这资金大控制
谁是新的黑马股
有没有可能转单呢
对 有转单题材的
还有呢
什么叫均线靠近的题材
什么叫均线靠近的
就是短中期的移动均线
全部都纠结在一起的
就跟刚才的这个台积电一样
它只要拉一根长红起来
它就整个股价就上去了
好 那我们先看的是金像电
那金像电呢 刚才我们讲了
如果星星呢
它是PCB的问题的话
可能会有短线的集单
所以今天呢
金像电盘中的时候
是一度拉到涨停板
可是收盘的时候还是打下来
它是带量的收黑K
所以大家可能会担心
是不是出货
对 没有错
看起来有可能会再出货
可是呢
它的这个K线形态
还有移动均线
实在是非常的漂亮
所以我们还可以继续观察一下
而且这个底部的形态真的很漂亮
它今天是站上了
它虽然是开高走低
可是站上所有的移动均线
所以明天记住了
明天它如果能够量缩
收盘价站上1200块的话
因为今天的开盘价是1200块
它明天的收盘价如果能够量缩
收红K然后站上这个1200块的话
它其实今天的这个量
很可能就是一个换手量了
好 那我们最后一个看这个真顶KY
真顶KY 它什么都有
有可能会有接到转单
突然之间变成载版四雄里面
什么都可以的
对 没有错
而且它的这个K线形态也很漂亮
怎么说呢
当你看它的短期动线
全部纠结在一起了
今天拉出个带亮的红K棒
明天只要再继续的亮针
再拉出一根长红
譬如说站上了这个季线的话
它如果能够站上季线的话
那它这个短期移动均线
就全部开始上扬
形成一个多头排列了
那这只股票就很有看头了
所以我觉得这个真顶可以注意一下
另外一个534年的渐融
虽然它今天是留了一个上引线
收个倒梯子的黑K
那可是呢
第一个它的预估本益比才17倍
不算高
明天如果能够开高
然后留下引线收个红的话
把今天的上引线吃掉的话
這支股票應該很有反彈的空間
好 最近PCB的上游不錯
說剛剛施工有講到的金居對不對然後像最近的話富橋也有在動南亞也是印馬當尖對 沒錯所以發現了還在相對低位階的建容就是啊這邊非常謝謝施工謝謝施工有提到
現在看起來9月確實升息的距離往上跑
這個難免給市場帶來一些壓力
我們就看台股能不能把這個月線的位置給守好
因為畢竟我們的產業前景
真的是非常的亮眼
即使今天星星遇到這樣的事情
今天外資投信
還是站在鼓勵它的那一方
所以手上有的朋友
也許心情就不要太焦躁
也不急著一定要馬上換股
因為轉單效應恐怕是有限的
不如回來看
本來就體質好的
開法術告訴你也是很好
均線糾結籌碼容易往上拉抬的PCB
才會是您的首選
好 廣告回來題材獵人漢偉哥
也要來告訴我們了
MSI今天換股
裡面有一個很重要的成分
叫做記憶體
我們有全世界最強的納亞科
但是其他人會不會跟上呢
其实汉伟哥说很有机会
9月的话
还有所谓的苹果新机发表会
以前都说了无心意
但这一次加入了折叠机会不一样吗
盘面上今天平盖股是厉害到不行
除了光学
其实散热跟这件事情也有关
今天来请教汉伟哥了
今天大概就是尾盘这个MSCI
真的往上拉
让大家觉得挺开心的
也把量稍微拉出来
那你一直长期帮我们追踪记忆体
可是很多人说
为什么万千重爱指给南亚科
有没有其他的选择
那今天光学当然是最强的族群
板材跟散热也都沾到苹果光
对啊 因为我觉得很久没有讲苹果股
但最近真的不太一样了
那我们首先来看一下
今天整个记忆体的状况
第一个就是MSI的尾盘的
记录的调整
那第二件事情是大家追踪到
最近的现货价格持续在上涨
那因为美银
最近出了一个报告
它说以这个8月27号
上礼拜为止的
不管是16G的DDR5
DDR4到DDR4的
还有这个Net
你可以看到
整个年增成长非常可观
真的很可观
都不想要采买的人
真的好痛苦
对
那尤其是大家会发现到
16Gb的DDR4
现在价格是91美元
超越DDR5
所以这就代表说
为什么南雅科
是全世界最强的记忆体
因為它主要是做DDR4
所以目前整個漲價幅度
維持在高漲的狀況
對南亞科來講是有利的
那我們可以看到
美銀對於這個9月份的預估
现货价格预计在这个基础上面
再涨10%到20%
对那我觉得就代表说
目前记忆的事况
看起来是超级周期延续的时间
比大家想要来得更久
那我们大致上可以看到
今天整个台国的记忆体的表现
那刚刚提到的嘛
其实因为现在已经进入到
9月份面就9月1号了
陆续要公布所谓的8月营收
那我们可以看到记忆体相关的
从制造IC跟模组
整个7月营收
这个区块全面都红通通
因为几乎全部都创下历史的新高
那8月份刚看到
现货报价又在创高了
9月份合约价也会在涨
所以理论上来讲
你大概在今年的第三季
制造IC跟模组
他们营收继续创高机会非常的高
所以如果以现在情况来看
今天盘面上其实台股是跌的
但基地股票里面大部分都收涨
虽然说没有像这个光学镜头
那么样的一个激情
但整理上来看
我觉得代表说
整个资金慢慢有回流的迹象
那当然大家观察的指标就是
你可以看到制造当中那颗最强
因为它上半年赚了23.38
然后IC设计当中
金豪哥最强
因为上半年赚了27.58
还是有伦理的是不是
因为刚刚正想问你说
大家基本面都很好啊
怎么分还是有差啦
对大家就优先买这个业绩最好的嘛
那如果以模组厂来讲的话
群联它也是赚最多187.43
目前的位阶或整理形态
看群联看起来也是整理的
比较漂亮一点的
所以我们来看一下相关的一个现行
目前来看当然南尔科是这个全世界记忆体之光
都在创新高的路上太厉害
对因为今天他收盘价543块
刚刚好也收到历史的新高价格
所以你对比到如果大家去看美光三星海力士
他们都在季线下面
那只有南尔科一马当先往上冲
我觉得刚刚提到的
第一个他有台塑集团的加持
第二件事情
因為最近的法蘭籌碼
土洋同買大戶在那買方
所以我覺得籌碼的優勢搭配
台灣的特色是
每個月公布營收
所以有這樣的一個營收加持
記憶體的特性就是說
你好像撐過一個月
又有一個營收公布的利多
所以每個月都有一個期待性
那現在的情況我覺得納爾科就是
他其實雖然說你會覺得
好像短線上來到相對高點
但你發現到他跟月季線的
怪力並沒有很大
所以這個就代表說
如果未來再做一個
比較積極的補量
應該他有在往上攻高一波那整體上來看納爾科這一波股價比較溫是因為國際大廠沒有漲所以我覺得如果說在美光 三星 海力士他們畢竟已經整理三個月了
如果九月份他們股價能夠開始反彈的話
對南亞科或說對華邦店
這些所謂的機體製造廠來講
比價向會推升得比較快一些
我懂了 我們有全世界最強的南亞科
但其他人就可能要等到
比如我們落後的這些韓國 美國廠上來
大家就會一起跟了
對 因為職場還是要有倫理
人家赚的比较多
他们没有涨
那南雅克自己涨就有点说不过去
所以我们就派华邦店望宏
令人这种比较弱势来代表
那华邦店我觉得它优点在于说
你可以看到这边形态整理的差不多
军阶就比较多头排列了
那现领的部分
因为今天M4在做一个补量的动作
所以我觉得其实你可以看到
如果它这个月季线
已经开始到黄金交叉往上
也代表说这个量
如果能够维持一段时间的话
它股价毕竟以前两家是差不多
它创高它会跟着创高
现在华邦店已经大概
五月六月份创高之后
将近三个月没有创新高了
所以我觉得大家可以期待
是华邦店接下来
我们有些股长的动能
那当然因为两个背后的妈妈
不太一样
对台座集团特别强
对
那华星集团特别弱
华星集团加油
这是两集团之争
对面子之争
所以当然我觉得
华邦店可能需要
后面集团
不管被动元件
不管是他后面的
相关的一些PCB的股票
也能跟长的话
也许华邦店的一个动能
会变得更强
那接下来大家也可以看到
像在所谓的群联跟金豪科
好 群联真的
我想很多的官员朋友都说
获利已经好成这样了
然后潘董也到处去宣扬自己躲好了
到底为什么不涨呢
对 因为他还没来这里
所以他就没有涨大
也许他有可能
所以我们就看到群联的部分
你可以看到他也线紧也做好了
他现在所谓的季线跟月线
即将在最新出现黄金交叉
所以众多架构开始改变了
那最近你可以发现到
这边有一个大量
那個代量是所謂的
公布這個第二季的季爆利多
爆量長黑K棒
那我覺得它只要過這個代量高點
這邊量也出來
代表量價也開始出現
結構上的轉變
那群年的缺點還是在於說
投信真的不喜歡它
所以我覺得大家可能要期待
群年有強勢的上漲的話
投信的買盤要回來
那如果投信買盤沒有回來的話
你看外資雖然有買
這是被動性的買盤
那可能我覺得就要回歸到
它理論上來講
8月營收應該也會創造歷史的新高
所以那個營收利多
能不能推升股價越過大量黑K的高點我覺得就決定到台灣相關比較弱勢的模組廠有沒有一個龍頭老大在做一個代漲的一個動作那另外一個ICP設計就有金浩克的代表
創歷史新高也是蠻猛的
對 因為整個機體當中
納爾科創歷史新高
金浩克也跟著創歷史新高了
也代表說來到第四季
有這種所謂的記憶體的業績加持
又有ICP設計背景的一個公司
好像就有本益比
享有比較高的一個狀況
所以它上半年赚了27块
那加上下半年会慢慢的
这个获利会慢慢递减
对 但我觉得整体上来看
因为它本益比就是比较低嘛
所以我觉得就有这样的一个
推升的空间
那当它已经来到历史新高的话
你对爱普对于预创来讲
我觉得就有一些轮动比较
这三样股票我觉得目前
现行都做得还蛮漂亮的
那江小科丹今天创高之后
大家可以看一下
这个就不是法人的股票
比较偏向主力的股票
所以如果你手上有的
就严无限做
如果你没有的话
你就观察一下
过高之后
如果压回
拉回到无线附近
我觉得可以做一个
低档的承接
那另外来看到
今天比较整齐的是在
苹概股
好 万万没想到
我们现在竟然会有
苹果光重现江湖
对 这样的状况
因为以前大概大家
对苹果新品发表
就长得这样嘛
对啊 那也没有什么
好像特别需要讲的
但我觉得今年
比较差别的地方在于
因为股价有创高了
是
所以大家会发现到
苹果股价今年表现
比辉达更好
是
对 那台湾的
很多檔现在都穿到历史的新高
所以似乎在苹概股的部分
它就有这样的想象空间存在
那一样跟大家讲惯性
9月10号以前
通常苹概股会有一个拉升的效果
那发表会出来之后大家觉得
iPhone 18就长这样
手机就长这样
所以就有点这个失望性的卖压
所以往往过往
惯性是苹果的新品发表会之后
苹果本身跟苹概股容易出现股价拉回
但后面随着业绩存长
可能有新一波的一个动能
那我们大致上来扫一下
这次要发表什么
iPhone 18 Pro Pro Max
那但就是有更快的晶片
更好的拍照
然后更强的AI
今年Siri会有一个
比较好的功能的发表
那尤其是今年
因为换了一个新的CEO
所以会不会有一个新人
新气象
对硬体对软体的一个整合更好
我觉得应该会给它一点面子
好所以我们来看一下
今天这个相关的平概股
其实表现就有点红通通
除了台积电本身来讲
今天是有点拉尾盘上来
但是你可以看到光學鏡頭
其實尊衡著你也在創新高
真的好厲害大力光從5000、6000、7000快8000對那玉金光也是一樣來到1000塊 一千樓以前大家覺得玉金光好像六七百就上不去了
現在1000塊了
那折疊期的部分
你看到新日新跟富士達
富士達也創造了歷史的新高
也很難得
然後到三熱 齊紅 雙紅
齊紅 歷史新高 雙紅也接近新高
到今天的一個所謂軟板族群
華通跟台俊
那當然組裝代工
還是比較溫吞一點
但我們可以很快
掃一下這些相關個股
那首先看到这两个光
你看8月17号讲也没多久
半个月而已
就已经涨了五成
这也是快五成
这个两光已经不两光了
对 因为如果只是平盖国的话
是不能涨那么多啦
对 那还好他们有CPU的光通讯
所以这个光的加持
我觉得比较多的是光通讯那个光
而不是苹果光的光
但我觉得他们最少就是因为
他们有平盖国的底子
所以这两家公司在起涨之前
大概光本益比大概二几倍
預金光不到20倍
那現在兩個拉上去之後
都在三四十倍的本益比了
所以代表目前本益比偏高
但因為跟這個聯亞
跟穩貌跟全新比較起來
好像本益又合理了
所以這兩家公司
當然很簡單
剛剛提到嘛
9月10號之前
我覺得可能短按來看
都還有創高的空間
那比較特別的是
你會發現到
他們漲這麼多
居然都沒有被關
因為現在
分盤就要變兩分鐘之後
好像就比較少聽到
然後對啊 為什麼
因為業績很好
對 他們業績很好
业绩有底气
不是那种腰股
对因为获利是有跟上股价涨股
但我觉得就是你可以观察
这一拜如果续涨的话
也许就有处置的风险了
那整体上来看
你看这两家公司
投信是在重压大力光
投信真的超爱大力光
对那投信也在压
所谓的郁金光
所以我觉得这两家公司
就有比价的效应
那这两家上去的话
大家会觉得都这么贵的股票
你就可以看到
联谊光啊
先进光啊
阳明光 雅光等等的
金国光
对那我觉得这些都是
整塊光學鏡頭
可以做一些比價的效應
我覺得這張股票
就把它當作神主牌
一直創高的話
你手上有一個恭喜你大家
那我們再看到下面的
所謂的散熱雙雄
齊鴻也很厲害啊
創立水高
其實富士達也有散熱的題材
對
雙鴻終於好不好
不辜負我們理財大人秀
一直Push雙鴻
他現在今天漲停板
但這個消費性電子比重
就比較高了
對 那齊鴻
當然主要還是在水冷散熱這一塊
雙鴻有一半是在消費電子
那剛剛提到嘛
因為iPhone18
聽說它的發熱會變得更高
所以相關的散熱的一個
零組件會有升級的狀況
所以对双红来讲
就来到所谓的一个
手机拉货的一个动能
所以我觉得这一波双红
总是比奇红
甚至说比高利来更强
是因为它在反映
平概股的拉货情况
所以目前股价
我觉得双红相比
奇红相比建策
好像就是老三的价格
比较委屈了
所以它利子新高1305块
我觉得是有机会越过的
因为你目前也可以看到
投信跟外资同步在买房了
那散热但奇红
还是这个投信爱股之一
我觉得这两档股票
也都可以为时偏多来看待
都有那种大哥头线
已经买超久
现在跑来买二哥三哥的现象
对啊
就是大家会觉得
其中好贵
那可能看到双红比较委屈
股价就开始积极往上补涨
所以我觉得双红
目前这个底型
打得还蛮漂亮的
今天刚刚多头排列
也许后续有一些
爬升的空间
那接下来看到
两档给大家
很熟悉的平概股
那只是说过去讲平概股
就讲这两档
就会摇摇头
因为觉得好像每年
都不太会涨
就比较温了
但是华通的话有这个SpaceX的题材
偏偏之前SpaceX的大家也没那么青睐
现在好像感觉上要动了
对SpaceX有点在起射
那华通之前但是又有一个
现增的一个卖压
对那目前我觉得在这个卖压
大概宣泄告一段落之后
股价现在占到所有捐纸上了
那你说会不会回到305.5
那我觉得就看到如果SpaceX股价
在接下来有续涨的话
应该是有机会
因为毕竟它有什么平概股的题材
又有相关的转单的题材
那台郡但最近台股相关软板出现很热
是你说台虹这类的
对台虹这类
那大家想说那台郡会不会有些受惠
PPF1概念
对但我觉得产品是不太一样
那台郡纯的我觉得是跟折叠机有关
对对软板来讲我觉得有加分效果
所以我觉得台郡但观察
就是后面那个折叠机
目前应该会卖到缺货
那如果说未来出货动能
比大家想要的更好的话
台郡应该是有机会
目前股价就要小心的是
它过往关心就是平盖股发表之前
来到高点后面就回答
所以我觉得整体上来看的话
如果你手上有的
就沿无线做一个偏多的操作
如果手上没有的话
就观察一下
如果他回测的时候
看一下大幅筹码
有没有在这个礼拜卡会完之后
下礼拜开始减码
如果有的话
我觉得可能就还是回归到
其他多题材的板材股去看
对 因为台队很有趣
之前有一度嘛
就是要离开苹果供应链
后来又重新把它打回来
就苹果光还是蛮诱人的
是的
这边非常谢谢亥伟哥
好 亥伟哥
很长期哦
一直幫我們追蹤記憶體南亞科今天叫做收盤的新高但是還有很多其他的记忆体位阶都还没有那么高在等什么等韩股 美股等他们也来做表态反应的话
我们相关族群
应该可以顺势拉一波
因为现在看来9月
价格还会再往上涨
明年预估的这个成长性
比辉达的70%可能还要高
这个都值得留意
再来苹果光的加持
固然没有错
但多题材可能还是相对
比较稳一点
近期长得凶的
跟蘋果的連動是高的
但新品發表過後呢
可能多題材也會
重回到軌道上
這個也提供給您做參考
好 廣告回來
雲翔哥要上場了
雲翔哥的比賽
在今天要告一段落
排名第幾呢
總收益有超過一億元
雲翔哥做了什麼事情
好 實戰高手要告訴您
他現在看上的是
特化股跟SpaceX
新鏈供應鏈喔
好半導體展
又是史上最大規模的
即將要開展了
等一下雲翔哥會告訴您
整體半導體他真的非常喜歡
而裡面的特化股
事實上最近是有股票
在往創高的路上表態的
所以看高做低是蠻多選擇的
這邊來歡迎雲翔哥
因為今天是8月31號
你有一個比了四個月的比賽
今天晚上要公布最後的名次
一起問你機器啦
好 然後另外當然除了特化
还有SpaceX概念股
先看一下这个
这个是从那个
应该是五月份
五月份开始比的吗
五月就是这个时间点
这个时间开始比的
五月到八月底
所以四个月
对
然后指数的话
就是说大概是震的10%
因为七月曾经有跌破这个入场点
这一场的话
对 这一场
很多人在这样
大洗牌
对
所以大概四个月
那四个月
我那時候大概
初期的投入資金是4000萬
先投4000萬
對 4000萬
不過我可以
籠子多少滿
也就是說
那最大的一個磁場
可以到快1億
那總資金4000萬是
收益是250%
因為現在剛好
寒今天的話
是剛好破1億
今天有在砸下去
就對了
那不過這一次
因為確實比較競爭
因為它這個
不是用收益率來
來比
不只比收益率對 它是完全就是不管你放多少資金它就比你的收益這樣子比純收益嗎純收益 對那不就是誰有錢誰的手幣就出嗎對 會比較有這樣的
當然也有可能它會虧很多
不過這裡來講
你會發現第一名
對啊 第一名大概
大概這四個月就做了
九百多億的金融
九百多億
都快千億了
第一名是誰 我看一下
LaBron James
什麼東西 對
怎麼跟他比 他很有錢
所以它大概收益到前一天
是大概7.5億
7.5億的收益
那2 3 4就很貼近
大概就在1億左右
對 那第五名就大概
要7千多萬
就拉開了
前十 前十當然都有獎盃
不過當然基本上
大家在搶前三
所以現在來講是坐視望山
等一下你為什麼要把你的本名
叫冠軍操盤手
人家是Lauburn James跟文斑亞
所以确实我把这个
反正没差
对 就把它列出来
那这一次我觉得说
当然这个收益一亿
这是真正的实单
所以那户头
30万的户头
目前已经2.28亿了
这是实单交易
大家要理解
这个不是虚拟交易
年初我记得是8888
对 所以已经过了2.28亿
所以这里面
刚刚照尔有提到
说大概做什么
其实跟我讲的东西
那当然差不多意思了
就是看高做低
然后找一些
大概本益比较
落点比较优的一些标的
就可以稍微有避开
像这一波我有避开
其实7月5还是赚的
近期来讲有一个半导地展
应该是明天嘛
对
好 8月31号就有论坛
今天有论坛
9月2号后天
对 开始展
那其实这一次来讲
其实围绕了
当然都是跟台信的关键性
非常非常大
这是一定的
对
所以这里面你来看
就是说大概有几个
比较这个是摊位的位置
基本上第一个来讲
一定是材料
另外来讲就是封装
那封装里面当然还含了
这个面板级的三处型封装
这里面来讲就是说
一些高阶的封装基本上也在
那再来就是设备
设备非常多
非常多 密密麻麻
包括设备也包括了这些
像这个厂物的部分也都有进来
對 那設備啊 軍華 軍豪 蒙利 加登
這個都基本上跟設備相關都有
好 材料的話
可能這邊展現的沒有像最近有像中華化長新對 應該也都會去啦都該也都會去看過像長新也有積極在展展對 因為它是主要是台積電它主要的一個供應商
所以這個一定有
所以這裡面來講就是說
剛剛提到就是
這個所謂的一個
半導體技術特區
記憶體也有
高峰論壇
對 西光子上也太熱了
這一盆也有
所以在這裡面來講
這一次當然會集很多
聽說廠商有1000多家
歷史最高最多
那我先談一下
因為大家可能很久
沒有去談到特化
而且他們的位階高低差異很大
那特化裡面
其實最近有很多股票都快創高
因為像中華化 長新
應該都在已經是歷史的一個高點位置
那當然你會發現說
其實特化裡面
很多它基本上它的營收
一直有在創高
也代表說確實
你如果跟台積電的供應
關係很強的情況下
那当然它这个创高是无格厚非
所以你可以看说像台特化
对不对
这是台阶界最大的一个供应
对 但它比较吃力
对 生意也是
那生意大部分的一个供应来讲
我等一下会提到
那中华化是它转型
它等于是原本是比较传统的一些化工
它有转型到一个
等于是电子级的一个部分
所以它基本上收益也开始起来
不过这一面来讲
就是刚刚有提到一个
就是说确实
因为很多它的本益比
还是蛮高的
对
中文化来讲
已经大概就是
60倍的一个本益比
所以这里面来讲
当然这里
森伊它的一个本益比来讲
我觉得就是相对还是偏低
大概就18倍
因为它今年
我们大概我记得
去年开始我们就有
大概提到这一支
有提过
那时候有估说
今年应该有到
大概7到8块
因为更好
可能会到9块
因为它的营收一直在创高
对
那毛利也在起来
那我先讲一下就是说
大概以像常新跟中华化
这两次来讲
你会发现它离高点来讲
已经大概很接近了
然后他们都是之前
从二三十块
就是很便宜涨上来
现在也还百元下面
落点来讲都是从
大概三四十块左右
这个中华化也是从三十几块
曾经拉到一百多块
现在又来到这个位置点
那当然我觉得说
确实跟它所谓的转型
因为这样子其实都是比较
从传统一直过来
常新像它是胶材的部分
那现在也是电子级的一个胶材
對 跟半導體關聯性很大
中華化一樣
那這裡來講
我就說可以看一下盛益
為什麼
因為盛益基本上來講
就是台積電的供應裡面
他是做大概有幾個
〔此段辨識失敗，約 40:00 起〕